تكبيرات تختلط بازيج الرصاص عيد السودان
يبكي اهله باعداد شحيحه في المصليات
يخرجون من المساجد فرادى لا مصلين
يرتادونها كما عهد عيد الفطر فرحته
بازدحامهم لكن بعضهم لم يابه كثيرا بتلك
المعارك فخرجوا رغما عن الصراع ولبوا نداء
السعاده بمعايده مغلفه باطلاق النيران
وكل عام
عيد لم تكتمل اركانه في السودان كتب على
اهله البقاء في المنازل او الخروج لاقتناص
صلاه بصحبه الاقارب او الاصدقاء والعوده
قبل ان تخطئهم باروده تلك الاشتباكات لا
حول ولا قوه
فرحه مسلوبه الا من امنيه اتحد عليها
السودانيون يرجون فيها ان ينعم بلدهم
بالامن والاستقرار
الاصلي
بالامن والاستقرار يعني ربنا علينا
بالسلام والبركه والخير يعني وتتوقف الحرب
والناس توصل يعني لاتفاق سلام والناس تعيش
في امني وسلام
ان شاء الله الوضع يتحسن ان شاء الله
الله اكبر
الله اكبر هكذا كان السودان على الاقل منذ
سنه لكنه يعيش مشاهد غير مالوفه يغص بها
البلد الذي اعتاد التهافت الى شوارع تفوح
فيها رائحه حلوى العيد ومن ذاك العام الى
هذا العام تكتب حرب الجنرالات ان تبقي
ذكريات العيد الماضي حاضره بطقوسها في
مخيلتهم لا وقعهم المرير اسراء الصغير
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات